common question that has come up a lot
in the last year and a half if indeed
Donald Trump and Vladimir Putin are in
cahoots
what has the Trump administration done
to help Vladimir Putin anyway right and
previously I've given you quite the list
immediately upon inauguration the Trump
team started looking at returning those
seized Russian diplomatic compounds to
Russia we know about the Trump Tower
meeting with Russian lawyer Natalia
vessel Metz kaya where Donald Trump jr.
intimated a quid pro quo to reduce
sanctions via the Magnitsky Act if
indeed they were they were able to get
that dirt on Hillary from the Russians
that would presumably ultimately help
them in defeating Hillary Clinton in
November of 2016
they were successfully able to lobby the
Republican Party to soften their stance
in the official Republican platform with
regard to Russia with regard to Russian
aggression in Ukraine it's a very long
list but I have something to add to the
list today I hope you're sitting down
The Daily Beast has broken the story
that a senior Trump national security
official had the idea of pulling some
troops from close to the Russian borders
as an open and direct overture to
Vladimir Putin early in the Trump
administration this is according to two
former Trump administration officials
this was ultimately not done but it's
major because we know in addition to all
of the other things that we already know
that senior Trump aides were looking at
moving the u.s. military around merely
to please Vladimir Putin when you talk
about national sovereignty when you talk
about America first when you talk about
what's best for the United States moving
troops to please Vladimir Putin is not
exactly what I would describe as an
America first policy is it a former
Trump aide said this that to them this
smelled like a quid pro quo and that the
reason that this was being considered
was as a favor to Russia for their
investment in helping Donald Trump
achieve the White House back on
of 2016 there's another implicit
revelation in this though
the fact that was so the individual that
floated this idea is reportedly a deputy
assistant to Trump for strategic
planning okay deputy assistant to Donald
Trump for strategic planning if a deputy
assistant to Donald Trump knows that
they might want to do things merely to
please Vladimir Putin that means that
the Russia stuff was widely known
throughout the Trump administration well
hold on what do I mean by that what I
mean is if the contacts connections and
possible coordination with Russia were
truly limited to just a couple people in
Trump Tower right in the Trump campaign
and administration you wouldn't have
even deputy assistants thinking in terms
of well what might please Vladimir Putin
because they wouldn't even know that
there was a reason to try to please
Vladimir Putin when I read that a deputy
assistant for strategic planning was
thinking along the lines of hey how how
could we please Vladimir Putin to me
that signals that it was no secret that
there was this relationship between
Putin Russia and the Trump campaign and
that makes it even less likely that
Trump was in the dark about it right if
we believe that Trump was in the dark
about it we have to believe that it was
like Flynn man afford Papadopoulos and
maybe a couple others that knew about
the Russia stuff but once a deputy
assistant to Trump knows about the
Russia stuff how can we believe Trump
didn't know yeah and is also showing
that it was sloppily done - I mean if
you're trying to get away with
corruption and collusion what you want
to do is concentrate that in just a few
hands but the fact that some low-level
staffer seems to be aware of all this
privy to this information seems like
they're not really running a tight ship
yeah it almost seems like their
potential collusion was handled really
sloppily like it they were it's it's
stunning what is implied by this
revelation and it's now very difficult
when the Deputy Assistant for strategic
planning was thinking about pleasing
Putin how do you believe that Trump had
no clue and the other thing you have to
consider is that while Trump is
narcissistic and self-aggrandizing and
concerned with his wealth and power
above everybody above all else he's not
merely gonna just give stuff to the
Russians and get nothing in return if he
can get away with it so there are two
possibilities one is well the list of
overtures to Russia were returning
favors that we received that that Trump
received from Russia during the campaign
the other possibility if you believe
that Donald Trump is doing this stuff
for Russia but or considered doing it
but never got anything in return
there's only other one possibility which
is that Russia had Trump over a barrel
and he was completely compromised
because the only way someone as greedy
and self-centered as Trump would give
something to Russia without getting
something in return is if he's scared
because of what they know and they could
blackmail him yeah and so many people
try to deny the Russia story by saying
well there really isn't a long list of
things that the US has done for Russia
since Trump was inaugurated the real
question to ask is what would they have
done for Russia had the public not known
about all that's right had the story not
broken in Europe and we've learned about
Michael Flynn texting during the
inauguration about hey now that this is
happening we're gonna be able to do this
deal and that deal and the other deal
what did they want to do is as as a
relevant question as what were they
actually able to do and we'll continue
following what the latest revelations
are